if you want to get us 844 204 rich to
chat that works as well
or just on the 49ers you can get to call
into the show york the ceo right here at
top
second hour on the rich eisen show how
have you been chad i'm i'm good i
thought we were talking notre dame
football today
oh my gosh you know what jed much
much like that uh gambit to start this
conversation
uh rudy was offsides same thing just
like you right now i think he jumped
i think he jumped did you jump the snap
i think i
i i'm just proud that i i i think we
have the the best
collegiate football program in in
in america right now i'm i'm excited
about it now you oh well now
now you really believe that though right
you really believe that right now
about i mean football like pure
collegiate football program what does
that mean
i know anyone what are you
what are you are you insinuating are you
implying what are you doing
jen i i just think our student athletes
and and the guys that go there
for just an education i i feel like we
have we have the best
pure student athlete program in the
country so are you
are you are you you're talking up the
provost on the campus of south bend
right now
absolutely they've done a great job
they've done a great job
hey the coach is terrific i love when he
comes on the show brian kelly
i think he's terrific i i'm i'm very
very happy i
i think notre dame is not the easiest
place to be to coach
as as is your alma mater not the easiest
place there's
very very lofty expectations um
and i think brian's done an amazing job
with the expectations and
i think he fits very very well in south
bend it's awesome to see
chad york here on the rich eisen show
the ceo of the san francisco 49ers
always kind enough to
spend some time with us right here on
this first day of june
anything going on with your team lately
chad i haven't seen you you know on the
headlines
at all what's going on with your team i
mean we don't have any more draft picks
to trade so there's not
there's not much to do right now i love
that let me just jump in
here um because there was so much
conversation as to how it all went down
and how it did work
its way to trey lance being the guy
chosen
by your organization did this start
where
you know like hey um it's a weekly
meeting or it was just placed on your
schedule coach and john want to talk to
you john lynch the general manager
sit down and they laid out hey we want
to make a monster move up the draft
board is that how it gets presented to
you and your part
of this uh of this machinery here in the
four hours
yeah i mean i think they saw the the
class and they were definitely
a number of guys that that were
intriguing um
and just knowing that we wanted to be
respectful
to our current players we we didn't want
to do anything
you know where we were having sort of
sneaky meetings and trying to you know
be
stealthy like we wanted to just make
sure like if we're going to do it we're
going to do it out in the open
and make sure that we did the entire
process and and evaluated all the guys
as thoroughly as possible
and let everybody know here who that
decision could affect
like this is what we're doing and and
we're going to be very very
straightforward about it
and you know there's a lot of meetings
there's a lot of
i mean i can't remember how many guys
and how many times that they saw each of
the
the the prospects sort of in person and
going to pro days and things like that
but there were certainly a lot of things
and you know i i could tell fairly early
on how focused kyle was
and i just i just sort of pulled back
where instead of getting updates
off of every time they watched film and
you know every time that they saw
somebody in person or had a conversation
it was just like
look when you guys are ready to sit down
and make the decision you know we'll get
together the week of the draft and
that's sort of what john and kyle
decided
uh i can't remember the exact day but i
think we got together monday before the
draft
uh that was the final day that we got
together but i'm i'm hitting the wayback
machine all the way to
probably late february early march you
know when that trade was made
because i you know again i know you're
very prideful as well you should
uh of putting together uh an
organization um
after the turnover that that you went
through that the coach and the general
manager and then you delegate that's
that's what they do
but i'm assuming you know all that draft
capital that gets moved around for a
player that is going to eventually
be your new starting quarterback does
require your check mark
right oh for sure okay i mean we had
that conversation but i mean it was
the check-ins in between were i
i mean you can tell how focused kyle was
yes it was like you don't
you know your decision week to week day
to day
doesn't really matter so i i definitely
shifted gears from there so we tried to
not
it was like one of those things where
it's hard to not talk about it
but it was like look like we're not
going to put that on the agenda anytime
we get together
because you know kyle kyle can change
his mind
you know based off of different things
and it wasn't
it wasn't worth it to try to go through
it at that point but i mean if you go to
the wayback machine it was
you know this is the decision we're
thinking about making and if we do it
we're we're going to be bold
and and again i think it was important
for us to be
to to really control our destiny and
know
that we were going to get you know we we
knew that we weren't going to get to the
first pick
we were pretty certain that we weren't
going to get to the second pick
so we we knew that we wanted one of the
the the next quarterbacks that we're
going to go
um and we just talked about how to get
there and what we were comfortable with
and again
having the amount of trust and respect
that i do for john and kyle
makes it so much easier to make a
decision like that of course i hear you
but so in other words you jed york ceo
of the 49ers
said yes to a trade based on what you
heard from your coach and your general
manager who you trust implicitly
without knowing the name of the player
that was gonna eventually be spat out on
the last thursday of
april that literally is something you
said okay
go about your valuation there was no
player that they said
this is the guy who's in the leader in
the clubhouse
when the trade was made i mean can what
what can you reveal about that
no leader in the clubhouse i mean it was
really there were
you know you you essentially knew who
was going one
right i mean i think we all knew who was
going one right i
i don't know that that you knew a
hundred percent who was going to but you
had a pretty good idea who was going to
so there were really you know three guys
plus
you know potentially a fourth if he
didn't go
to the jets that you were really looking
at so it was really three guys plus
another just in case
he didn't go to the jets and i
i think they felt good about all of
those guys
uh early on and you know they're all
intriguing i think they're all
going to be very successful guys in the
nfl uh i'd i'd
rather not play against them but you
know i don't i don't get to choose
who other teams quarterbacks are so that
that's something that that's a rule
change that i'd like to
implement at some point it's ted york
here on the rich eisen show so
um did you were you were you rooting
for like not like you're you're you're
grinding all 22 but did you have
somebody that you wanted in mind and
that you're
you're glad that it came out or what
like
i mean i'm i'm very glad how it came out
and again i i think
it i think i've said this before it was
a lot easier
you know to choose who you wanted versus
who you didn't want
because you can make an argument for all
five of the quarterbacks that went
that that they should have been the
first quarterback to win and
you know they're they're things that you
can debate about all of them but i mean
there's there's a lot to like about all
the quarterbacks you're in this draft
and for me like i'm not i'm not studying
their film the way that kyle is or the
way that john is
you know and in terms of the people like
i think they
they're all great young men and
i think trey is going to be fantastic
he's he's a phenomenal young man but
but all the guys were so it wasn't like
well you know this is a great player but
there's a character issue like
there are no character issues with any
of the guys there there were no
off the field things there there's just
you know it was a very very unique group
of
of young men and it was uh it was a
really cool process and i think the
world of trey lancy's he was on the show
two days before he became a 49er and uh
you know he literally had me at hello
and it's just i can't believe he was
he's awesome like he's i can't believe
he was born in the year 2000 man i i
just can't believe that
yeah it's uh that's that's a little
weird
that he was born in the year 2000 but
you know
we'll we'll get over that that's an us
problem it's not a hymn problem
obviously right that's right that's our
that's us working on our own
our own issues there um so uh when is
the question did i hear you in an
interview elsewhere say you think jimmy
g could be the start of the next two
years did i hear that
yes i mean really you know i mean that's
a nice thing about drafting a young guy
is that you know when he's ready to play
he's ready to play like you you look at
you know another quarterback that there
have been rumors about
it it took him three years to play and
he's had a pretty nice career
um and and again i i think
you know we we love jimmy i think jimmy
he got us to a super bowl
you know like there's a lot of great
things to like about jimmy
and that that's the thing about when
you're looking at the quarterback
position
the the amount of money that that a
quarterback you know
demands and and and and sort of takes to
to be able to
to feel something that's not a rookie it
is a lot of money
and there's obviously a savings to
having a rookie quarterback
so some of that savings goes to you know
a guy that can help you get back to a
super bowl you know a guy that that can
play very very well
when when he's stayed healthy and and
has done a great job like you did in
2019 for us
i have no problem having two really
really good answers at quarterback there
and allowing a young guy who just turned
21
you know to to get his sea leg so to
speak under him like there's
i have no issue with that whatsoever now
that aforementioned
uh quarterback who's in the news that
did take three years to be the starter
that was in a time however
when there wasn't a fifth year option
and
you know and winning in somebody's first
contract in the nfl was at such
paramount importance based
on what you just said the cost savings
of having somebody on a first
contract in the nfl that doesn't factor
into your
i mean that that doesn't factor into
your thinking as
as uh a chief architect there in in
santa clara
so i mean if i said this to you if i
said the first two draft picks
that that we had two number ones are no
longer on the team
our best draft pick from our first class
was our was our fifth round
selection and you know are
are you excited about your team going
forward
you know are you excited about your team
like do you think your team is going to
get to a super bowl in year three
if you're two first-round picks from the
from the first year
are no longer on your team you'd
probably say no
you probably say like you know this is a
disaster this this didn't work
and i think that's where everybody looks
and says you know well you know it's a
first round pick like it has to be a
home run right away
i i'm looking at the entire the entire
picture
like what are we doing to be successful
and i think you know obviously we didn't
have the the year that we wanted last
year
in terms of you know our record but the
things that we overcame as an
organization as a team the injuries that
we had being
kicked out of our home and going to
arizona like
i think we we showed a lot of a lot of
fortitude
and i feel like we can compete right now
whether jimmy's a quarterback whether
trades the quarterback whoever it is
and you know if jimmy gives the best
chance to win then jimmy's going to be a
quarterback
so we're going to spend the same amount
of money
as anybody else in terms of the nfl and
the salary cap
so whatever that makeup looks like as
long as we're getting to the right
result
like i'm i'm comfortable with it and
plus i guess you got to
just live with your decisions and live
in the moment because we could all be
gone by sunday right jed
i mean we could be i mean i have no idea
if we're going to make it this sunday i
heard that
i'm hoping that we do were you one of
the people who texted your coach to
on that sunday to say i'm still here
like kittle did were you one no
no no i didn't i didn't but but in
speaking of george yes
i like i mean i think george is he's
easily one of the top people in the nfl
like just just an awesome guy
an awesome awesome awesome football
player
first person ever to do a handwritten
card
for me to say thank you for a new
contract
ever in the nfl since 2005 my first year
first guy ever to do a handwritten card
what he do
he sent you a thank you note handed me a
thank you note he
he lost it last year after we had done
the deal
and i mean with with all the moves and
just everything like he he
had it in his in his storage because he
moved to nashville with his wife
right i mean he's like i found it and
he's like i just wanted to hand deliver
you a card
and beautifully written card thank you
note the
first time i've had a handwritten note
from from any player
for doing a contract no kidding yes
signed george thanks thanks chad for for
the
for the long-term deal the only other
guy that i have a handwritten card from
yeah we didn't do a deal with any
guesses
ah well i mean jeez can you give a
little bit of a hint cause i can go just
a slight subset here
he played he played catch with your your
head coach
under the radar at duke peyton manning
that's correct what was that about well
he's a he's a he's a known handwritten
note guys so
after he signed in denver you know when
when we didn't evaluate peyton
um even though jim and and and jiro went
down to
to duke to to work him out and throw
with him
peyton wrote me a handwritten note after
so the only two guys peyton manning who
didn't sign with us and george
who who did do an extension so what is
peyton
writing you like thanks for watching it
was just thanks for
thanks for the interest in me wish you
guys all the best you know this was
before he signed in
in denver no kidding yeah oh my gosh
now i feel like i should write you a
notice for something i'm not i mean i
feel like that's
like sort of like you if you write me a
note you're probably going to go to the
hall of fame
like that well okay so all right well i
i was going to end this conversation by
thanking you for calling in but uh you
know a note's coming your way
how does that sound jed it sounds great
sounds great
thanks for the call thanks for the call
absolutely man i'm hoping to see in
person soon it seems like things are
opening up yeah
for everybody i guess let me just ask
you that question are you expecting to
have a full house like is that a
i i i know obviously uh the the health
and safety protocols in your county
is uh what sent you elsewhere uh
last year we are you know as as things
sit today we are
we are in in the clear to be able to
have
a a full house obviously things can
change
but that's our expectation right now and
that's as a as the guidelines sit today
that that is our expectation so okay
because i know the state of california
is opening up
fully you know um on the 15th of this
month
of this month so practices everything
you're you're expecting to have as
normal and normal as possibly can be
when you're
oh gosh green bay packers on sunday
night football that's the first one i
just looked week three
how you doing that might be a big one
where alan chris won't be wearing masks
in the booth and they'll be calling the
game
that's the way it would look right i
that's what i'm hoping
that's what i'm hoping with the
aforementioned quarterback that we have
not named that your coach apparently
called his coach for
right that guy judd i i i'm not sure
what you're talking about i think
i think our interviews are i i don't
want to i don't want to miss your
commercial break okay thank you
i appreciate you being concerned about
my radio clock jed thanks for the call
appreciate it absolutely thanks richard
that's jed york everybody jed york i
follow him you should too
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here